you spoke at the November 4th
demonstration in Washington called the
free Palestine
March it had a lot of people several
hundred thousand people there what do
you remember from that experience well
the first thing I remember is that there
was no news coverage of it so 400,000
people march on DC one of the largest
marches in history it was nowhere to be
found in mainstream media coverage
whereas when the stand with Israel rally
happened between the 300 ,000 strong
Palestine rally and the 400,000 strong
Palestine rally there was a stand with
Israel rally where Congress men were
were bust uh from Congress to speak at
that rally uh Democrats and Republicans
and high-profile celebrities and it was
you know live streamed uh across
multiple places I mean I have to say
this the
icj if that wasn't the greatest display
of media bias in you in in the domain of
United States mainstream media then I
don't know what is they live streamed
the Israeli defense on multiple news
outlets defending itself against the
case for genocide and completely omitted
the South African
presentation of the crimes of Israel the
day before so what I remember first and
foremost about the protests is that they
were nowhere to be found on mainstream
media which was expected but what I also
remember from the actual day of and from
all of the pro Palestine rallies is that
I have never seen a more multifaith more
diverse group of people consistently
coming out for Palestine against the
genocide in Gaza that I have this time
around and I think that has been the
experience all around there has been a
pronounced Jewish presence Jewish voice
for peace if not now other anti-zionist
Jewish groups groups that are against
the genocide against the occupation
former Israeli soldiers even um
you know that have been showing up at
these protests there's been a pronounced
presence um uh from Native American
groups indigenous groups all across the
board right Christians Jews Muslims I've
never seen more diversity at these
rallies that I've seen this time around
which I think is a sign of where things
are going and if you look at the under
35 opinion polls it's very clear that
there's a generational Gap here that the
country is moving into uh a more
coherent Direction and understanding
what has been happening over there and
people from all backgrounds are standing
up to it now what do you think about the
protests on
campus against Israel every protest I've
been
to has had the exact same tenor has had
the exact same messaging but you always
have that idiot or two that shows up
with a
sign and no one knows who that that
idiot is ironically never comes with
anybody else always shows up somehow in
the middle of the protest and puts up a
sign that says something completely
contrary to the messaging of the protest
and all the cameras shift towards that
guy I see it every single time but the
overwhelming tenor of all of these
protests has been consistent it's been
calling for Freedom it's been calling
for Liberation it's been calling for an
end to the genocide a ceasefire an end
to the occupation and enter the
apartheid I will tell you what many
people are not seeing Columbia
University two IDF soldiers former IDF
soldiers spraying Palestinian protesters
with skunk water which is what the IDF
uses on Palestinian protesters and
sometimes on worshippers on their way to
Mid
AA uh which has multiple uh Health
repercussions and so I was reading about
how one of the students that was sprayed
on campus at Columbia Palestinian
student you know has showered at this
point of us doing this podcast 11 times
cannot get the smell out of her has
suffered all sorts of health issues as a
result of being sprayed again people are
not seeing the other side here people
are not seeing what we've had to deal
with at these protests right the open
bigotry and I want you to think about
this by the way people go and serve in
the ID and then come back to the United
States or the United Kingdom and they're
not stigmatized for participating in a
parthe policies or participating in a
genocide how am I supposed to feel as a
Palestinian knowing that this guy right
next to
me participated in murdering my
relatives in Gaza right and has open
Reign to say what he wants to say or do
what he wants to do and so we haven't
seen the other side of that as well but
i' I'd recommend to anyone that's uh
talking about you know Pro Palestine
protests to actually go see one if you
go to the protests you listen to what's
being said you don't just capture I mean
you got 400,000 people uh don't just go
try to find you're going to find four
stupid people at 400 at a protest to
400,000 people right because the protest
scene is always messy but I think that
this is um a sign of the
outrage and the anger and the
frustration
that many students have about being
silenced again in the media in academic
settings um professors are losing their
jobs students are having their faces put
on trucks being doxed uh the Shady watch
lists that get put out I'm on a few of
them as well and I just don't care
anymore right but you got these Shady
watch lists people are losing their uh
their jobs at law
firms uh they're losing all of their
future opportunities young Palestinian
students because of something that they
they tweeted that's being taken out of
context 10 years ago right when they
were 17 years old it's ridiculous and so
I think that um you know we have to we
have to listen to the overwhelming
majority of voices of people that are
demonstrating for justice not
demonstrating against anyone but
demonstrating for people uh again
there's a large pronounced Jewish
Presence at every single Pro Palestine
March in fact if you look at uh the
organizations the groups that have taken
over uh Capitol Hill and and you know
train stations it's been if not now not
not an our name never again means for
anyone right it's been Jewish groups
many Jewish anti-occupation groups that
have been at the Forefront and I think
that that's where we have to pay
attention to the beauty of how diverse
this movement for free Palestine has
actually been so the average sentiment
is
anti-occupation not
anti-semitic it's incredibly lazy
incredibly lazy to say that anti-zionism
or that anti-occupation is anti-Semitic
first and foremost the Palestinians are
a Semitic people that's number one
number two
um look I'm proud of my community my
community has stood against
anti-Semitism in this country the Muslim
Community has been at the Forefront of
condemning anti-Semitism we have stood
in front of synagogues we have stood
with the Jewish Community when the
Jewish Community is attacked this is
about occupation this is a story of a
colonial entity that has driven us out
of our homes and has done so in such a
way that has forced us to try to be the
voice of a people that are being
exterminated overseas right now this is
not an anti-semitic movement this is a
Pro Freedom Movement do you think the
protests ever go to too
far the protest scene is a messy scene
and so again you're going to have
sometimes that odd speaker or people get
carried away in their emotions and yes
sometimes people chant things or do
things that are contrary to the protests
it's pretty unfair when you judge the
entire protest Movement by some of these
incidents that have happened at protests
and you don't pay attention to what
they're protesting about in the first
place which is a genocide right now
everything is secondary to ending a
genocide that is ongoing in the course
of this
discussion it's not an exaggeration to
say that at least 30 40 people would
have been killed just over the last few
hours because we're averaging 135 to 150
a day
so everything else is secondary to that
this is where we all need to be right
now as people of conscience how do we
stop this because every single day it's
is deeply
costly